welcome everybody we've got refreshments
afterward and we really hope you'll
stand around and get to know each other
at the end of our session so to talk
about what's going on the most up to
date information we can get about
Southeast Asia entrepreneurship and the
ecosystems to support entrepreneurship
in the in the region I have a wonderful
panel a very fortunate that we can be
joined by three distinguished experts
let me introduce them briefly I'll ask
each of our panelists to give us maybe
seven or eight minutes of prepared
remarks then we'll go into a Q&A format
so sitting furthest away from me
is miss Christina Laskowski and
Christina is a strategic adviser and
management consultant in consumer and
technology companies for 16 years she
was a investment and M&A banker where
she helped to raise over two billion
dollars and she was also in the founding
team of consumer research at Hamm
Brickman quest she currently serves as
the president of s TAC stack which you
see on the slide and stack is a
nonprofit organization that is focused
on driving economic growth in the
Philippines through entrepreneurship and
Christina played a key role in
transforming stack into a advisory
organization that provides various
proprietary services she presented a
five-year plan to the Philippine
president in the year 2010 and her
leadership really resulted in a
countrywide movement to support tech
entrepreneurs the launch of the first
three angel funds in the Philippines in
2012 and back in 2010 the Philippine
president gave her the Golden Heart
award with the rank of
grand officer and she's regarded as one
of the 100 most influential Filipino
women in the United States sitting next
to Christina is Ms Madhu aya Iyer and
Madhu is a seasoned executive for
start-up companies and investment firms
she has been on the board of directors
of a unicorn startup she's was the chief
data officer of a Khosla funded Series B
startup in the San Francisco area before
coming back to the San Francisco area
she was chief data officer at go Jack in
the Philippines in Indonesia where am i
today sorry
go check the uber competitor in
Indonesia and she also set up the
Singapore operations of Kojak and before
she was in Southeast Asia she was on the
founding team at Intuit for the
QuickBooks small company lending
platform QuickBooks financing and she's
got multiple patents filed in the United
States she started her career as a data
scientist at a think tank and Menlo Park
which will remain nameless and she's
worked and lived in many different
countries in the region and sitting
closest to me as mr. Denis Fernandez who
has over 20 years of experience as a IP
attorney in Silicon Valley for the
high-tech industry he is a strategic
adviser to leading venture capital firms
including seven Rosen and Venrock and
Charles River ventures and also Walden
international his client companies read
like a who's who list of people here
including this University and he's also
on the Editorial Board of the
nanotechnology law and Business Journal
and the board of directors of the
Association of patent law firms
and he's on the board of the staff right
the Science and Technology Advisory
Council he served on a consultancy for
the UN Development Programme on Asian
economic development and he's also a
patented inventor in areas of digital
television and since her networks and
also bioinformatics so we've got an
absolutely great panel and I'm going to
ask our panelists to give prepared
remarks in the order that I introduce
them so first up is Cristina the floor
is yours thanks so much for coming I was
excited to participate in this panel
because I you know I've always been an
entrepreneur at heart in terms of
enjoying to build things and as we go
through the presentation I have today
providing some information I'll I'll
demonstrate to you why it's been
exciting to be part of stack which has
helped build this entrepreneurial
ecosystem in the Philippines in an in a
region that is increasingly becoming I
think more significant more influential
and more innovative so yeah on the first
slide what I'm going to do in my
presentation is share with you some
information about the region the role
that the Philippines plays in the region
the all the activity that's going that's
taking place in the region so here on
the slide is just a slide demonstrating
or showing to you which countries
represent the ASEAN member countries the
Philippines is one ASEAN is the
Association of Southeast Asian Nations
many of these were developing countries
and now considered emerging growth
countries you've probably heard of a
number of unicorns that are in the
region today if you went back six or
seven years ago there was very little
going on at that level and now it's it's
become much much more you know active in
the region in terms of tech
entrepreneurship and entrepreneurship in
general
here's a slide just to demonstrate the
growth how growth of five of the ASEAN
countries compared to growth of the rest
of the world it's growing at an average
six percent as of 2016 or five percent
sorry five percent okay really and
direct investment has played a major
role we've we see about or we saw about
two hundred seventy four billion dollars
of US direct investment into the region
between 2004 and 2016 does this say what
kind of things people are investing in
to do direct investment um no not
necessarily a lot of that a lot of the
investment has as well in the country
infrastructure and those are large
ticket items typically but nonetheless
that plays an impact in terms of the
amount of capital that's you know coming
into the country and into the region in
particular so with regards to
entrepreneurship Southeast Asia is
considered a two hundred billion dollar
digital opportunity smartphones you know
that most of these countries of
leapfrogged never really got into
purchasing a PC or even having landlines
you know I'm sorry internet set up
through their landlines it's really a
wireless and mobile play in the region
and this is one of the reasons why it's
also generated a lot of interests with
market participants there's some
interesting lines here under talent it
says that they see Southeast Asia as a
future pipeline of senior sea level of
talent yeah exactly and that's and and I
was actually gonna highlight that that
because a lot of these countries have
never gone through the cycles that we
have here in the United States and maybe
in other developed worlds there's
there's a need for more senior level
talent sea level talent to help expand
their growth to bring expertise into the
country and and so in terms of
entrepreneurial opportunities that are
there if you're looking
to become acquainted with the region if
you're looking to do something new be
part of something exciting helping to
build what's happening in the region
it's it's pretty much sort of the wild
wild west new frontier it's definitely
you know the region to be in right now
so here's a slide just of just
illustrating the total funding for
Southeast Asian startups you know up to
2016 so there's about to more than two
billion dollars that was invested into
startups in the region most of that is
an early stage so you see a lot of
capital going into seed or early stage
rounds of financing although there have
been more and more companies that have
been receiving later stage rounds and
going into the G Series G right now but
that's you see fewer of those you see
more of the early stage type of
investments that are going into the
startups in the region and here again
it's just another slide just from
another source see the insights just
talking about the financing for tech in
particular so we talked about the the
previous slide was about investment in
startups and this is more focusing on
the amount of investment that's going
into startups in particular and you
could see it year-to-date
last year there there were 286 startups
that actually received funding tech
startups so there there are technology
related startups that are in the region
in the Philippines that's been
interesting because it was really a
consumer type of environment especially
on the entrepreneurial front starting
stores doing retail etc but we've seen
that transition you have more companies
that are more startups in terms of the
online Karma's on the online commerce
side and also digital payments in
financing side as well as social Honor
Enterprise that are emerging and this is
what I mentioned earlier here's the
slide just just representing the deals
the funding and the deals that are that
are have been funded in the region and
most of them are in the early stage and
it's because the region is is fairly new
in terms of the entrepreneurial activity
and tech activity and this is just more
data in particular just to demonstrate
or to show to you how much money has
been invested in on the seed round
series a B C and D these slides on our
website so it will be able you can
access the data here we have some in
donation founders here and and within
the region Singapore and Indonesia has
attracted the most amount of investment
Indonesia is really interesting because
it's a larger it's basically it has a
larger population there's a lot of
excitement I I know that China is
starting to invest more and more in the
region but this is just demonstrating
where some of the activity is taking
place in the region Singapore also leads
in funding rates for the top 10 funded
Southeast Asian companies you can see
here that Lozada grab SI air trunk and
tracks image basically raised a
significant amount of money you can see
lazada actually had has about four
billion dollars in total funding and
again so singapore definitely lead in
that area and then if you if you move to
the next slide you'll see that Indonesia
follows with travel oka took a pedia and
go check and then and then Mata Hari
mall and then iflix and Malaysia and
iflix
serve that the Netflix for Malaysia yeah
those are larger they're increasing so
over time the amount of investments have
increased and I think as more and more
investors you know become aware of the
opportunities that are there the
ecosystems have also developed in the
region I mean they there are
accelerators in the region there are
more investors in the region a lot more
money being deployed into the region in
fact Eduardo Saverin who's one of the
cofounders of Facebook he's based in
Singapore right now and so he has his
own fund
and he's also he's a limited partner in
Moncks Hills fund as well he's one of
their is one of one's Hills limited and
he definitely recognizes the opportunity
that that exists in the region today and
here I just mean it provided a slide
just to show with the logos of the
various startups that are in the region
right in ASEAN and other Asian countries
we don't really focus on you know India
and China because they're pretty large
and significant much more developed but
some of them may appear on this on this
particular site just to show you that
yes now we've got a number of startups
that are in the region funding that's in
the region a lot of you know
opportunities that exist and here the
next few slides will just what we're
just highlighting the most active
investors so 500 startups
I think 70% of their investments are
outside of the US and they've continued
to build that presence they've got 500
durians which is another fund kylie was
just here last week speaking at an event
and talking about the opportunities but
they will invest as little as $5,000 in
a start-up which goes a long way in
Southeast Asia so that's another thing
to pay attention to that that when
companies look at the region they're
also looking for runway and if they can
extend the amount of money or the amount
of that investment to go much further to
help develop you know whether it's
software or whatever application that
they're trying to do or whatever
business that they're trying to build
it's definitely much more attractive in
the ASEAN region because it could go
much further with the talent there and
here we just we provide a list of the
other top Southeast Asian investors so
here are some of the newer Southeast
Asia funds if you're not familiar with
the sea investment in the region I
thought it would be helpful to show this
because again it doesn't demonstrates
that because of all the activity and
opportunities that are in the region we
have more funds that are actually
emerging
you know to focus in this area and the
Chinese have actually you know Chinese
companies have actually taken a lot of
interest and what's happening they're
starting to participate in basically
inject a significant amount of
investment in other companies and you
can see some of the activity that
they've done between 2015 and 2017 and
then here are some philippine startups
that i just wanted to share with the
audience that have emerged that are 4
years and younger so a cue dean actually
helps you know they're just a more
efficient way to address invoicing some
of the small businesses are strapped and
what they do is they actually collect on
those invoices for the businesses so
they'll they'll cover the invoices and
they'll collect on their behalf so that
the small businesses are not are not
constrained by having a lack of capital
because their invoices aren't paid I
think sometimes invoices take about four
to five months to receive payment and
they came up with a very interesting
solution and I and they want a
competition last year does it match is
just a it's very similar to zip Realty
which is a platform for buyers and
sellers to find real estate to learn
about what real estate is available and
and also to market your your property
okay so thank you while I'm changing the
slides I've got a couple of follow-up
questions for you the first one is
really so Southeast Asia to what extent
is that kind of a fictional entity I
mean you've got eleven or twelve
different countries right 11 different
countries in ASEAN and each country
really is kind of different are you
starting to see the region kind of hang
together more business-wise well I I've
seen it here so another group that we
formed that that stack is a part of we
co-founded a group called the ASEAN
Alliance which is essentially a
partnership between SF Asia which is the
office of economic
development in San Francisco block 71 SF
which is a sink which is the Singaporean
startup home here in incubator in in San
Francisco M Dec Americas which is
Malaysia digital economic Corp we also
have a partnership with Sebata which is
Sevilla Silicon Valley technology
Alliance which represents Indonesia and
then creative ventures which represents
Thailand now I bring this up because
what we recognized as each of us are our
organizations are serving as a bridge
between home country and Silicon Valley
and we felt that a collaboration of
sorts would make it would be much more
powerful for the entire region because
what we envision is a region where
you're going to start sharing talent
there might be some challenges today in
terms of how how easy or how challenging
it is for you to go between countries
but we feel that the region in itself
can be somewhat similar to Silicon
Valley and serve serving as a melting
pot where all these talented individuals
from the various countries come together
and work together to build companies and
we've seen that Singapore has a number
of philippine founders there was an
indonesian startup that also had
philippine founders so there is this
sort of cross-pollination that's
happening within the region okay great
why don't we move on and after the next
set of comments I'll start to ask some
more questions
modern mismo ire if you would talk about
your comments the next light and then
the slide off the next because this is
just an introduction to me well actually
okay all right you've done a great job
introducing me thank you I wanted to
talk more this was you know it was a
great macro sort of an introduction to
Southeast Asia and the landscape I
wanted to drill down and you know I most
recently spent time at go-jek and you
know in a private equity firm in
Singapore building FinTech startups all
over Southeast Asia Indonesia
Philippines primarily and you know on
the ground what we see is
I've just seen two big trends that I
wanted to highlight and there's a ton
you know and I was very difficult for me
to sort of pin down the two and I can
talk about the rest in in the comment
sections but Chinese investments and
regional you know cross-border
activities are two really big ones and
in terms of the Chinese investments next
slide I the same you know the same thing
that Cristina kind of had up it's such
an important and omnipresent
you know activity right now China
started in 2015 with Alibaba and you
know their financial arm and financial
Tencent didi and Jada calm which is a
big e-commerce player in China obviously
they started investing in if you look
across lazada you know you look at and
then you know MDOC and mint you look at
go Jack you look at grab and travel oka
you have not just different domains
lazada as e-commerce you know tokopedia
ecommerce you have MDOC and mint
hel-hello pay they're all the FinTech
and then you have the sharing economy
which is go check and grab and then you
have travel oka which is you know travel
you know travel ecommerce in out of
Indonesia you have these different
domains but almost every important
country in Southeast Asia is sort of
covered by China you know you have
hollow pay which is Malaysia you have
sorry touch-and-go is Malaysia you have
you know go check obviously is Indonesia
Lozada is Singapore and all over there's
there's a low pays Philippines div and
then you even have something like an
ascent payments which is silent so
they've got their you know they've
basically got a hand in every single
country and investments in different
domains and I think it's a really it's a
smart move and I also just and this is
you know my own sort of personal opinion
but an opinion that's shared by a lot of
VCs
on the ground there that there's a lot
of people from the US trying to get in
Walt but there's not this substantial
you know an involvement other than
Amazon perhaps which is you know on the
ground you know you even have you even
have OB OB key which is there which is
basically a a Content firm out of
Thailand so they've covered everything
get different veins can I ask before we
go on yeah
is this purely portfolio investment by
the Chinese companies or do you think
that they're really moving toward
foreign direct investment and then on
toward takeover and and so my next slide
was sort of gonna allude to that but my
I think it's the latter
I think it's lazada the lazada
mothership has truly arrived in
Singapore
Lucy Peng is now heading lazada she's
been sort of transported from the China
office over to Singapore and you know
that speaks volumes III think it's you
know it's more than foreigners
investment okay the one owned is what I
think it is yeah just the way they've
kind of moved you know this is a deep
dive example go check which is you know
which is where I was at it's an example
kojic has just raised 1.2 billion Google
has invested and I think Google has a
strategic next billion users sort of an
angle there and I'm happy to note really
as you know as an American that Google
is now there in an investment at go-jek
but you know obviously $0.10 has come in
and invested as well and here you have
you know go right go car you have
logistics you have food you know you
have other smaller services like go
ticks and go Mart and this is across 50
cities in Indonesia and underpinning all
that is cashless payments in the form of
go pay and so I just you know wanted to
kind of give you an example of how much
there is a penetration from a Chinese
investment point of view
you know in Indonesia and I think the
other big trend is the regional
cross-border activity I know you'd ask
this question to Christina I think that
for e-commerce lazada is you know is
headquarter in Singapore but it has
offices obviously in the Philippines
it's all over and you know I also think
that you know a major sort of a synergy
with e-commerce with the growth in
e-commerce and cross-border is logistics
you have fulfillment you have last mile
deliveries you have software solutions
that enable faster ela gistic s-- and
really if you think about it you would
think you know logistics is a single
market play but the market is so
underdeveloped that ups and you know DHL
kind of you know bigger players find it
very tough to compete at the low per
package cost levels and you know and so
you have like ninja van from Singapore
that's expanded into you know into
Indonesia and so there's a lot of
interesting sort of like interplay
that's happening from companies in
Indonesia penetrating to Singapore and
vice-versa and of course we all know
that you know the share economy which is
grab and go check the go check is now
planning to expand to the rest of the
region grab is already present so you
know it's and of course FinTech with
remittance and cross-border payments and
cash lists which is a huge you know
which is a huge push I really think that
crossbar is sort of the only way to go
in Southeast Asia as no one country has
both supply and demand and you know
there's the ASEAN you know the way they
do business there's the tax implications
it's it's it's pretty you know it's it's
all built the ecosystem is built to sort
of you know help each other before we go
further how do you see the competition
between grab and go jack playing out
from now you're independent now you
don't represent anybody yeah thank you
thank you for that disclaimer Graham's
been grabbed has raised a lot more money
than Gajic and Gajic has sort of been
the underdog in terms of raising money
but in you know and then of course now
the grab and the uber you know merge
that's a powerful
you know that's that's obviously a
powerful indicator of grabs omnipresence
in the area in the region I do think
that go-jek is you know it's a personal
bias you know I love the Indonesian
ecosystem
I think Gajic has excellent market
potential in terms of just the different
kinds of things that they've done very
early on yeah I mean you know it's just
like from go massage to go ticks they
they want to be in every single sector
and I also think that they've got
something you know go studio now which
is content so they they really are
getting into everything in a very big
way
and so go check has always had the
advantage of the diversity and grab
finds it and they had go resto which is
you know restaurants love of food so I
think this mentality of gorget to sort
of be extremely nimble when it comes to
different product offerings you know
it's going to be a it's it's for
everybody to see in 50 country 50 cities
in Indonesia is a very difficult number
it will be willing to to speak out on
that okay thanks very much mother so
kind of as a follow-up question for you
the brands are all different you know
because the Americans are not there
right you're not see well you do see
Amazon trying to do things and so forth
but this is a very different ecosystem
in terms of the startups that have been
successful and so forth do you see the
American companies waking up or what do
you think is going to happen I think you
know I just think that the way of doing
business in
Indonesia you know in in Southeast Asia
is a little different people sells the
way people use Facebook or Instagram
here so I guess I guess and you know a
bigger comment is that everybody uses
Facebook and Instagram so it's not like
you know the service and the products
are not there it's just that you know
there is a lot of it's a gap there is a
gap between the products that people are
using and how they are using it for X
for example people in Indonesia sell
stuff on Instagram or sell stuff in on
Facebook and you know the Americans
don't use Facebook for the same reason
or Instagram for the same reason so the
reasons we use our products is very you
know different way we use it here in the
way we use it there it is a very hyper
local play at the moment and you know
you have to understand the demographic
and how things are done there there is
also the entire urban and rural mix you
know which we have to consider by 2025
even half of the population is still
going to be in rural areas in Southeast
Asia so that's another huge gap that I
think it's going to be difficult to be
you know be sitting here and saying no
this is one reason the opportunities for
go-jek to offer all of those services
you you know the infrastructure hasn't
been rolled out yet right exactly and
infrastructure has not been rolled out -
yeah okay thank you very much Dennis
you're going to talk to us about
innovation in the Philippines I will try
thank you yes I I've done a lot of
different things you know I teach patent
strategy in the Philippines I helped
Christine oh and stack I manage a patent
firm in Silicon Valley and I launched
one of the earliest venture funds in the
Philippines also in Singapore and
Malaysia from Walden and you know I go
back there to go scuba diving
it's like it's one of the best places to
go the biodiversity is amazing I I
wanted to just share a few takeaways one
is the context you are alluding to in
terms of demographic influence
Philippines is very much a crucible
colonial influence even today and in
fact to the point where it's difficult
to identify what it means to be Filipino
because the Filipinos you meet here tend
to be identified with their regions as
opposed to the core Filipino identity
which arguably some people think doesn't
really exist because of the colonial
influence by Chinese even today the
investors Spanish we're there for well
over 300 years
so most Filipinos you know have Spanish
last names they're Roman Catholic and
they love Christmas okay it's
interesting because you know a lot of
people may not be aware of how many
dozens of languages there are in the
village the dialects show the fragmented
when you have a an archipelago of
thousands of islands you know it's like
koala bears that evolved in Australia
well Filipinos pretty much stayed on
their islands for a long time and they
kept speaking their local dialect and
then even today the American influence
is significant and you suggested the
branding question probably more than any
other country in Southeast Asia the
Philippines is probably the most
Americanized and more most receptive to
american-style marketing even with
recent pressure from the deter to
presidency to challenge
the parental control by the US on the
Philippines alright so you've got a
hundred million or so filipinos very
high poverty rate I've seen number is
much higher than twenty one percent but
it's the fastest-growing country in that
region economically and that's driven
largely by a very stable banking sector
and a strong political base compared to
previous years of you know off of
autocratic leadership very small
entrepreneurial community 300 or so only
10 or VC funded last year okay so that's
an opportunity but then you have to ask
yourself why not okay part of it is the
infrastructure is really hard to you
know when I go out there and go diving
in the remote sites even though I have
my smartphone it's it's very hard to
find communication but there's a lot of
cyber cafes so it's it's a fragile
infrastructure it's it's changing now
quite a bit drivers
Christina suggested earlier a lot of
Internet related services one big area
is in healthcare okay so the Philippines
produces lots of nurses and doctors most
of them get exported there is tourism
for healthcare to the Philippines okay
like other places and so that that's
that has a good platform for
exploitation by a strategic entrepreneur
in the US there's over three million
Filipinos and almost 2 million of those
are in California ok and this context
it's not just statistically interesting
this is strategically important and
and so I think you know having done the
VCE deals in the Philippines you cannot
ignore what that means strategically
because it's a tight community very
Americanized the other piece of that
puzzle on the colonial influence is the
Philippines is largely controlled not by
government but by a few wealthy either
Chinese or Spanish families and so when
we set up our venture funds there we
pretty much have to pick who your
strategic family partner is and then run
with that and then from that point on
your arrival of the other families so
that's what it means to do business in
the Philippines even today all right
Philippines leads in Internet use
especially through social networking in
the region and it's not surprising
because of the nature of it's a very fun
buoyant culture you know very vocal a
lot of fun there I saw one study a few
years ago that ranked the Philippines is
one of the happiest countries in the
world even though it's one of the
poorest with earthquakes volcanoes
typhoons super typhoons and yet the
happiness index is extremely high
like ahead of Canada Canada it's also
very high anyway so this is important
you have to understand that you have
this kind of context in terms of social
use and I just want to share that
anecdotal point is next slide okay yeah
and then finally this is kind of the
segue to Christina's Aussie and stuff my
take on the ASEAN thing is they would
love to unify like EU or the United
States but it it never happened when I
was there doing the
in the mid-90s I think what's unifying
ASEAN today is political against China
that's militarizing the region so there
is concern that you know China's
outreach to secure Southeast Asia from a
military standpoint is forcing the uh
the ASEAN countries to decide whether
they will stand on their own or be part
of the Chinese umbrella okay and
actually under the new president that's
been kind of there's been some it's a
real issue yeah yeah it's a real issue
Philippines won a World Court decision
about Chinese development of a coral
reef and built a military base on it so
if you want to learn one Filipino word
thank you memorize salaamed that's me
with my sharks with your short and sharp
Republic iPad okay yes yes they just got
eliminated Dennis thank you very much so
do you really think there's only 300
startups in the Philippines I mean I'm
kind of curious what they're counting
but cause you know on the one hand we
try to make a distinction between
Silicon Valley style startups that are
really going to grow hugely and go to
exit versus local SMEs right better
better because but must be a ton of esta
needs in the Philippines there's a lot
of real family-owned businesses that
have evolved into local industries some
of them are heavily agricultural like
sugar and other things I'll tell you how
hard it was when we when Walden
you know I managed our Philippine fund
also from San Francisco the regional
Asian fund I had literally to go island
hopping
and just to find deals and they were
tough they were like prawn farming and a
new mall or some kind of yeah you know
it is low-tech and as a patent attorney
and you know I have like my own
portfolio patents it's not the fabric
for innovation to innovate ahead of the
global curve what it's not a driver it's
a follow on behavior okay this is part
of the colonial thinking I think and I
don't want to be harsh because you know
I wanted to support the country and wish
them well but it's not going to be a
place where they're going to move the
needle or disruptively create something
new that will make okay I just don't see
that you can't build up the first
industrial base before you have to
disrupt it yes yes and so I I think
there there is a strategic flaw and
presuming that you can just export
Silicon Valley angel VC funding models
to a country that has major
infrastructure shortcomings okay
and now the the groups that are fundable
are real okay so it's so you know 300
maybe 500 I mean I remember when
Christine was out there helping them
write business plans over like it are
you period coaching no it was really
hard okay and but we tried you want to
help you know we love our country and
also not to pick on the Philippines a
couple of years ago in this series we
have a speaker from Thailand and his
main point was don't try to put the
Silicon Valley model into Thailand this
is just not the way people develop
businesses I mean you're starting to see
more of it developing this way
approach I mean I don't think I mean
even when we started our work we didn't
we didn't have that mindset of we're
going to transplant Silicon Valley here
what we're going to do is basically
implement best practices but localize
our approach so it was very local
Oklahoma and even the even the
businesses that we reviewed may not be
sort of embraced by the market here but
from a local perspective they were
solving problems in the local market and
you know and it's since evolved but yeah
we did not have that mindset of we're
gonna transport Silicon Valley here our
mindset really was its implement best
practices in supporting entrepreneurship
Oakland as a way to self-sufficiency
yeah it's a different way of developing
businesses there but when you come to
trends there's AI there's cashless
payments there's you know and there's
fin tech in terms of lending and most of
these are and mobile you know Mobile is
a bomb knee channel really and most of
these require skills that are sort of
Valley like and so even though you're
doing business there in a different way
you have to build the businesses
thinking about the demographic and the
classical sort of what's adoptable there
you have to think about the skills that
are very Valley like online marketing
and digital advertising their reality
you need to have those skills they're
very sort of you know they're very
translatable there and also AI robotics
everybody who's anybody now in you know
in marketing platforms they say they
have chat BOTS and you know and it's all
sort of robotic process automation going
on so there is skills that can be taken
from here and there are sort of just you
know mirrored there as well and
strategic thinking of those sometimes
they're stuck in a box and you've got to
help them think through you know what's
gonna happen next right and how do you
position yourself against competition or
potential competition so I've got one
question for all three of you I'd like
to get your individual opinions on
partly because nobody mentioned
something I was kind of expecting you to
mention and part of this is because I
gave you absolutely no instructions on
what to prepare nobody mentioned the
rise of the middle class and how that's
changing spending patterns I think it's
implicit in some of the macroeconomic
data that you shared with us but I
wonder how the middle class might change
the nature of business opportunities and
also what role it will play in more
Silicon Valley style entrepreneurship
Christine why don't you go first I'm
probably about all across the region
because I think that one of the things
that impresses me is that all of the
countries in the region are moving into
that area where you know per person GDP
or per person income is sort of
middle-class ish and the macro
economists say that you know people
start to buy cars they start to do they
start to use our money in a different
way they start to invest more of their
kids education well education is a
priority so I don't think that will ever
go away in the remote look at it yeah
that is not new I mean in terms of
spending you do definitely see more of
the the middle caste or even the younger
generations spend more I don't know how
that's impacting saving though because I
haven't seen you know you know they
might be spending more but are they
saving as much as you know generations
past but there is an increase in
consumption and also the way that they
consume right the on demand way of
consuming the immediate you know
basically they want things now for
Entrepreneurship what was that what does
this do for entrepreneurship well it's
it's providing solutions right that meet
that sort of meet their needs and you
know they're more receptive to to
business models that their parents and
grandparents weren't even exposed to
back when you know being able to send
money being able to share the cost of a
you know the the cost of a meal right I
mean you
Solutions like Ben Moe where everybody
could just you could spot your friend or
do this it's very it's very different
and even just mobile payments etc that's
very different from how you know
generations past we're able to consume
and remit and do things so that's
definitely changing behavior on the
middle classes okay tomorrow I think you
know rise of the middle class income is
sort of implied in some of the
fundamental product innovations that
you're seeing that entire segments of
FinTech which is you know mint and asand
you know they are all about asand
money is all about how do you get people
that don't have access you know how do
you make like frictionless online
experiences come true and there's the
o2o which is huge or you know offline to
online there is there being solutions
that are being imagined which is again
you know Silicon Valley to their Silicon
Valley doesn't have this offline to
online problem as much as you know a AJ
does and so how do you kind of make the
entire experience of having online you
know online availability you know
basically if it being being available to
the middle class that might not be in
the urban areas even people that are in
the urban areas who might not have like
credit cards and so there's being
solutions imagined for that there is an
entire industry that's kind of rallying
around the rising middle class in every
single you know whether it be cashless
payments whether it be you know FinTech
visa vie FinTech whether it being
insurance for people whether it being
ecommerce there is there is a start-up
out of Philippines which basically is
lazada you know partnered with them
basically it was all about how do we
make the products on Lazzara
available to the lower middle class
people that are just you know having an
income rise and so yeah it's it's you
know it's implied it's implicit even
last mile delivery logistics these are
all solutions that are kind of you know
targeting just that okay good Dennis I
think there's a myth that the
Philippines is a democracy because you
see this vibrant press that debates and
and they vote however if you really
understood what's going on you realize
it's a feudal structure with an
oligarchy and so the notion of a middle
class which got gutted out in previous
decades through overseas workers and a
lot of immigration to places like the
United States in Canada I think it
chilled this notion of economic
revitalization through the middle class
either through creating a growing market
or as a source for entrepreneurial
activity site I'm a little skeptical
that the Philippine middle class will
drive you know Philippine
entrepreneurial growth I think it will
come out of the elite layer okay because
so popped oh yes and they have the
resources and connections and they're
very global in their some of them are in
this room and so they have access to
ideas and capital but the philippine
middle class to me continue to struggle
okay and and it's very hard it's very
hard to bridge over this social gap like
in india okay yeah certainly a
relatively small number of wealthy
families and controls quite a bit of
capital in india yeah and i think if you
understand that I'm not judging that as
good or bad I'm just saying look that's
how it really is you know once you use
that as your starting point and your
realistic then you can articulate a
strategic business plan okay so I'm
gonna go with one more question then
we'll open up to Q&A from everybody and
I'm going to start with you Dennis I
think one of the things that if you
haven't been to the Philippines that
might surprise you
is the kind of very active technology
cluster there I mean there's a lot of
people who do good software development
there and who are really quite heads up
in terms of new trends and software what
role do you think that's going to have
going forward is that going to play a
role and kind of a big economic level
yeah I'm I think it's real and it is
competitive and so you know Christina
and I and our colleagues in Silicon
Valley mentor these guys when they come
here and we introduce into customers and
and it's it's in part because there's a
certain layer of know-how that can it's
really agnostic to where you are on the
planet okay so you can create AI
applications or you know things that are
purely running off smartphones from
anywhere okay and so you have the cost
advantage and it's it's exciting for me
because it wasn't like that when I was
funding deals in the Philippines in the
mid-90s because it it just wasn't even
close to that okay
but now the quality of their vision okay
and their their technology is is very
competitive so it's it's coming okay now
okay kind of looking across region model
you are talking about talent do you
think technology talent will support the
continued growth
what about management talent how do you
see the needs and possible solutions to
those problems yeah I think you know
it's I have to agree with Dennis a
little bit here there is the brand you
know this is kind of bringing the
branding umbrella together and they when
the families America has a huge brand in
Southeast Asia and that's the University
brand people who have gone to Stanford
and Harvard and you know any of the Ivy
League universities or people have
studied here that go back that they are
the ones that you know get the
opportunities to manage
these startups found these startups get
the access to the capital and so there
is that which is the you know sort of
the you know they're the ones that are
present there in terms of the management
teams there's a lot of people from
outside going back in terms of whom in
grown talent you know I I see that I see
that there is a lot of need and they are
moving up quickly because of the need
that there is I do think that I do think
that there is a little bit of a struggle
to kind of you know quickly covers that
gap but there's a lot being done there's
a lot of you know
zurafa accelerator programs there's a
lot of programs that are catering to
like founder institute like singularity
people have now you know reached that
online so you know there is if there is
that but you know I think there's again
so I'm gonna play on your independence
now when you're working with Dell Jack
was it hard to find people who could be
data scientists people who could be
coders even just how did you deal with
that problem yeah I think management is
hard I think data science is even harder
yeah you know it's unfortunately data
science was new when I was back there
three you know a few years back and
India China have more mature data
science you know data engineering
ecosystems in terms of the talent but it
was hard you know but I think Indonesia
and the Philippines are putting a lot of
time into their university programs now
to teach these subjects and to have you
know independent you know for example
the Python Society for the are Society
of Indonesia there's a lot of meetup
groups that are coming up in you know in
the United States style that are putting
in a lot of effort to have homegrown
talent but it's difficult and you know
it's definitely much more there's much
more advances to be had there yeah
Kristina from your perspective
I mean I completely agree me one of the
things that we wanted to do differently
with stack is that we recognized that
access to knowledge network etc were
reserved for a certain group of people
and it's typically those who have
studied abroad have gone to like the
Navy League University in fact we met
with the managing partner of endeavor
Philippines which is basically this
global initiative to support local
companies that have the opportunity to
be global and they showed a slide and
and one of the thing one of the
questions I asked was what is the
correlation between all these founders
and where they went to school and where
they live because that is I mean it
tends to be reserved for that elite
group typically a full disclosure of
five of my board members went to
Stanford but but when we started to do
our work in the Philippines we wanted to
level the playing field no we had
competitions we said it's gonna be
national we're gonna go to all the
regions we're not going to be exempt we
are not going to host these events we're
gonna ask the local communities to host
because the other disconnect or the
other gap is even though you tell these
founders how it should be done what
should be done unless they actually go
through the process and an in every
iterative process it is a process in
which you learn that's why I'm driving a
car yes you actually do it yeah you can
read textbooks they can watch videos
they can learn all these things but
until you've failed or until you've made
a mistake or you know you've done things
you're not gonna really pick up that
knowledge and so you know we're trying
to help even with stock we have
conversations with the Philippine
government and to have help address this
gap they've got this program called the
black scientist program and I actually
participated as a scientist part of the
program even though I don't have a
science background but it was to serve
as a prototype for a but expect opener
program where we can encourage this
inflow of talent into the country where
they could be hands-on and really work
with some of the founders and
entrepreneurs so that they could share
their knowledge with the founders and
entrepreneurs in the country so that's
one way that we're trying to address it
but it is I think it is a gap I mean the
whole ecosystem sort of kind of can't I
think with the smartphones
you know in 2007 I think that coupled
with some other things that were going
on in the region
you know broadband access to all of this
that helped served as a catalyst for all
this activity that happened and so it
was a learning process for all the
ecosystem participants and I think we're
just seeing you know a few evolutions of
what's happening in the ecosystem today
so years ago I analyzed what lessons we
could learn from how Singapore a Taiwan
and Korea South Korea transitioned from
heavily agricultural economies into you
know globally competitive industrial
infrastructure you know cars stuff like
that and there were a lot of factors but
one driver that helped catalyze those
economies you know 30 40 years ago was
government resolved to build early-stage
industries like shinshu for
semiconductors and and strong incentives
and recruiting talent focused on
vertical markets when I look at the
asean cluster except maybe for singapore
i don't see you know heavy
capitalization and regulatory biasing by
the government to trigger that kind of
national mission and that's what's
missing because you're not gonna get it
from entrepreneurs writing apps or
early-stage was just a function of how
much money the governments have and
other things on the money's there you
know I talked it to guys with the Asian
Development Bank in the World Bank it
they'll fund infrastructure deals that
will fix you know national needs like
electricity and you know stuff like that
but this requires national leadership
and it's risky because they have to
commit to something that they may not
fully understand like
with cars or a blockchain transactional
platform or CRISPR healthcare
technologies I mean they have to come up
and the political will to do that in
countries that are struggling with all
kinds of localized factors it's not
there okay
Philippines is going after the drug
dealers yeah okay I mean that's their
national result well yeah yeah you need
that and it needs to be sustained for a
while yeah we had a good generation out
of the Cold War I mean it's a strange
thing to say but it's true yeah a lot of
that is really pre innovation that's R&D
fund but that really has helped the
Silicon Valley but the other thing about
here is we're very much an innovation
region relatively urban you know 100
kilometers by 120 kilometers and in size
maybe and you don't have to go in one
very far until the American economy is
very different so are you going to see
urban regions kind of develop the same
kind of regional Innovation Center
characteristics in Southeast Asia kind
of like you know we moved ahead of
everybody else and there's a national
danger there because if the rest of the
country doesn't feel like they're
benefiting from your development
eventually you will be punished for it
and you know Silicon Valley may be
punished over the next year's look at
our problems with Facebook so what do
you think are you are you seeing urban
centers kind of growing up in Southeast
Asia that are exciting there's a lot of
a lot of startup you know activity it I
mean it's spread across the country but
then there are definitely pockets but
you can say the same thing here in this
country right and
we're hoping that it spreads but again
you know if there's - if there are
individuals that are attracted to some
of these opportunities they're gonna go
where the opportunities are
yeah right and then it creates sort of
this again this ecosystem or mini
ecosystem within an ecosystem that
drives drives that well Rokon is trying
to change that here right he's having
visits with other states and rural in
overall towns helping us spread the
innovation across the street okay we're
hoping that that that happens in the
Philippines that it's not just limited
to those regions that's one of the
reasons why we wanted you know to do the
national competitions and encourage
folks all across the country that if
they have an idea that there are you
know there's support and there's a
network and bring the government's
attention to what's going on in those
areas model any comments about other
parts of the region either Indonesia or
yeah I think you know Jakarta is
obviously you know huge power center for
all kinds of startup activity in
Indonesia there is Singapore is you know
it's just kind of dovetailing on some of
the comments about Singapore there would
be no conversation about startups
without mentioning the words blockchain
and ICO you know in the current
environment and Singapore has you know
been the stance is a little you know the
mas s stance on i cos has been sort of
somewhat on the fence and I know I'm
sort of digressing a little bit and I'll
jump back to your question you know it's
just yesterday was the first you know
ICO that came out of Singapore blue cell
race nineteen point five million dollars
and ICO Singapore's really kind of doing
its best and so it's a huge epicenter
for a lot of activity it's regarded as
one of the most friendly ICO countries
in the world now you know and that's
sort of leaps and bounds you know in in
terms of taking an innovation
recognising it early on and leap
frogging
in you know in front of everybody else
but yeah I think just like the u.s.
Southeast Asia also has hotspots
where there's just a lot more
accelerators a lot more you know
founders that want to live and a lot
more talent lives in those parts of the
world you know
so that also talent is a huge thing as
well okay thanks let's open the quote of
the Florida questions go ahead Walter
you first
after listening I got the impression
that the business model involved with
three elements number one the wealthy
people to build the infrastructure and
number two you follow ads which can
serve the market at the bottom of the
pyramid and number three you collect a
lot of small money to grow a big bun
industrial profit
am i correct who you say mr. small what
is it buster a whole inch of the new
model so this is the way the ecosystem
works in my country at a national level
okay the way it works over that region
well one thing I noticed you left out is
what Dennis you said it's not there and
that's the government trying to really
this is the direction we're going to
move yeah the Philippine economy is very
retail centric okay so they don't design
new chips or design new cars so it's
they consume and there are some
businesses that are highly profitable in
a difficult market like the Philippines
like Goldilocks
restaurant chain and it fits exactly the
checklist you just talked about so it's
a micro economy that caters to very cost
sensitive services yes if you if you do
that and you really have remember when I
used to visit there quite a bit
it always freaked me out that there
would be guards at every major bank
office with submachine guns okay
and I thought what they must need that
okay and so you just have to realize
that you're doing business in a
difficult environment okay it doesn't
mean you can't make money okay and
your checklist is it's a good
distillation of what you need to do when
you embark on that journey I think it's
very doable this is why I kept talking
about here your context demographically
culturally you know the whole crucible
thing the whole expat Filipino American
community okay you have to exploit that
in a way that a good entrepreneur can
scale it okay I think that's why you
know in countries when when investors
look at countries in the ASEAN region
right they're looking at market
opportunity you saw a slide there where
there's 22 percent in poverty in the
Philippines that number could be higher
what is the total available capital I
mean what is your market and so if your
market is fairly small and then it's
represented by people who can only
transact in small amounts yeah you are
going to be targeting this this
basically this group of consumers who
can only pay the five you know ten pesos
or one hundred pesos or whatever it is
but you add it all up and it becomes
more meaningful and in a market like the
Philippines and maybe other countries
you might have a higher profit margin I
mean if you just go to the side store
it's called a sari-sari store they still
sell things in sachets which would be a
sample shampoo container here they sell
that they can make money on that right
and so it's kind of like the same
mindset too in terms of if you're gonna
transact online you know with with
delivery or whatever it is
I mean sometimes those the small
increments can actually generate
significant amount of profit in you know
with regards to the business but it is
you you do have a limited market it's
it's unlike the market that we have here
in the United States there is your total
available market for whatever it is that
you're selling is gonna be less than
what it is in the developed economies my
comments on this okay I saw your hand so
you know every pretty much every startup
successful startup story of her has
started with founder talking about
themselves identifying a need that they
themselves had and so I'm wondering from
my own standpoint being someone who was
born and raised in America even though
I've gotten what at this point I
certainly hope is a very high value
education I don't necessarily know where
I would fit into or if I fit into a
start-up space in Southeast Asia so I'm
just wondering if this is something that
interested me how would I go about
getting my foot in the door I mean past
attending talks like this and there are
these little you know side projects that
happen around Stanford but like how do I
get connected to a two person company in
the Philippines that does what something
related to what I need that's me right
there accelerator in the Philippines
launch garage I mean you I mean we're
we're accessible you know our role as a
nonprofit organization is just a serve
as a bridge and even not just the
Philippines if there are other countries
that are of interest that we can help
facilitate those introductions but you
have to ask yourself to not just your
education but what is it that you're
interested in what have you been doing
and then is you know you could do that
match in terms of what you have to offer
a company and what the company can
benefit by having you join their team
right it's a two-way can I turn that
around a little bit moto go-jek
developed in Indonesia at a time when I
think I wouldn't say uber was asleep at
the switch but Southeast Asia was not
really noticed by these kind of sharing
economy ride-sharing companies is that
actually a better kind of model because
now that go-jek is doing well they're
getting lots of large amounts of funding
from international players in that space
or do you see it as American
entrepreneurs would do well to kind of
that are their expansion opportunities
earlier yeah I think and that's that's a
great question I do think that you know
as all the things that I was I've been
you know joining with mind is that
American entrepreneurs when they are in
the series a or even seeds not seed
stage but I would say anything beyond
Series A Asia is a huge growth
opportunity and people just can't be
bothered because they don't know how to
do business
for example I've had people come to me
and it's a marketing firm and they're
doing something you know in its data
science it's highly artificial
intelligence oriented and they have for
example a L'Oreal come to set them and
say can you find me somebody in you know
in the in Vietnam that does basically
you know that how does the middle class
in Vietnam look like for a L'Oreal brand
and how do we go out to them and they
just can't be bothered to do that
because they have plenty of business
here they don't know who to go and reach
there how to set up ground operations so
you know it's it's a really I think it's
an and what they have in terms of the AI
here is unmatchable there so there is a
need and there's a genuine need to go
and you know these what they don't have
is the trainee model and they don't have
the training modesty and the other thing
is I think but if you've got eleven
different countries in ASEAN what you
don't really see is the fact that you've
got six hundred million people and a
huge percentage of the world's GDP
coming out of Southeast Asia male right
I think people are missing out there and
it is hard to do business it is out yeah
but there's a lot of cash in that region
too
there's a lot of cash and actually it's
not talked about in the media but a lot
of the larger companies are paying
attention to what's going on so they are
doing things in the background you know
to position themselves in the country on
the region yeah the way I would do it is
look at how industries in the US have
become more efficient
and you don't have to invent new
technology because their counterparts in
these ASEAN markets you know the bank's
the hospitals certainly the schools will
be happy to to use the best practices
this is like franchising Starbucks all
over Southeast Asia I mean the model
works and then it it grows really fast
that that works and I've seen that
happen many times it's not exciting to
me as a patent attorney because ii can
invent anything new they're just moving
it to a different part of the planet you
know although I have to say Southeast
Asia is you know and cross border and
all that is great but Southeast Asia has
microcosms of different sorts of icon
you know it's Vietnam is vastly
different to Indonesia is vastly
different to Philippines and so you know
is your is your addressable market
really 600 million or is it you know do
you want to concentrate on a country get
it right here at work and that's
argument for Indonesia they there's a
lot of concentration or interest in
Indonesia cuz they see it as a larger
right so I understand the investment
side but what are the rate of success of
them innovating in the marketing in the
Southeast Asia
other way to say what are the status
focusing on or local perspective is
there any like different song strategies
or how do you think about the success of
in general big players like
I think that you know Tencent has
invested in a lot of different countries
and a lot of different domains and some
of them have been really early
investments for example MDOC which is
basically a multi currency
you know trading platform out of
Singapore was very much under the radar
and you know and that's when aunt
Financial came in and invested in them
and so there are these kinds of
early-stage investments and they kind of
grew it and then they have operating
partners that come in from China and sit
on the boards of these companies sit on
the sea sea levels of these companies
and help it grow and so it's beyond
investment it's also operating in
partnership which is China recognized
that Southeast Asia
early on needed that you know that that
that pushed towards sort of how do we
get this operate you know this
operational to the next level and then
there are some later stage investments
and that's classically you know you've
seen it in lazada and Lazaro also has
been interesting because it's a much
later stage investment but still now
suddenly there is you know the
mothership is coming in and you know
Lucy Peng is sitting on the she's the
CEO now so the operational models are
vastly different and frankly you know
and then there's the you know go checks
of the world where they just kind of let
it run so it's all you know it's
different styles of management of these
investments you know that if I want
suing your question but I I do think
that Southeast Asia is too nascent and
even the startup ecosystem is too
nascent for there to just be sort of a
cookie cutter moral yet but they're
experimenting with different things and
they've been very successful the
valuations of the companies that they've
invested in has gone up I don't know the
exact numbers you know that and I don't
want to quote a misquote any any number
but the valuations they've been able to
provide significant lift in the
valuations I wouldn't be surprised if
it's also played for strategic and for
information strategic but it's really
understanding how all the consumers
behave in each of these markets
then using those those acquisitions as a
distribution channel for their products
right like they're like Xiaomi and
absolutely if they're gonna sell their
phones they want to sell their phones to
a new market let them understand the
consumers the way they behave they might
have applications that caters
specifically to those consumers but
they've gathered the intelligence and
they plant it there you know their
operations already in the country so I
absolutely agree with that it's consumer
behavior it's it's data it's just a lot
of you know there's a rough crystal ball
elements to this where you know you
don't know how they're going to be able
to leverage the the data maybe five
years from now and so it's a very
interesting development they are that's
a I think kind of is a way to sum up
what we're talking about you're looking
at a really new system yeah compared to
this the entrepreneurial ecosystem of
China is 20 years older right really
started to take off in the mid 1990s and
manes had a generation to grow this is
this generation the first generation
here in Southeast Asia so one reason we
didn't even have to talk about exits do
this because basically it's a little too
early to starting to talk about exits
and I think that what you're seeing is a
lot of economic activity you're seeing
an emerging ecosystem for
Entrepreneurship which leads to a lot of
challenges and difficulties but it's a
very exciting part of the world and not
to be ignored
we've got refreshments outside and I
want to thank stack for co-sponsoring
our refreshments today
and I hope that you'll stay afterward
with me and talk to our panelists more
outside thanks to all of you for coming
and please joining join me for thinking
a great panel thank you very much
[Applause]